what you want to say to these fans to
the people over the five years that this
tournament happened here so the people
who've watched you over your career
which has been one of the best in
counter-strike know one of the best in
eSports
[Music]
I play this game for twenty years
they've done BRE this game for such a
long time it means the world to me PSP
standing here I I can't really get out
the words that I'm feeling right now but
I'm just super happy to be here still I
did it I didn't know this would be so
painful for me but I'm just very happy
that still people are supporting me
supporting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when get red cried at ESL one cologne it
wasn't just because he'd lost the
tournament his tears marked the end of
an era something that no one wanted to
say out loud get ride was leaving ninjas
in pyjamas after seven years with the
org his run with the only Counter Strike
global Offensive team he never known was
over but that wasn't the only reason
that fans at home were crying with him
fans were sad because can't rice
partnership with forest was over that he
was basically breaking up with his
friend and teammate of over a decade but
here's the thing on paper forest and get
right shouldn't be nearly as popular as
they are they haven't won anything in
almost two years and in a scene riddled
with recency bias their popularity
should have dwindled so why does the
csgo community love a forest and get
right Justin Bieber that pops music that
swing it is smoothie ding-ding-ding
because their relationship transcends
both nip and csgo it's a relationship
that lives on in the entire community's
hearts a relationship that brought
everyone closer to the game and to each
other get right and forest popularity
has survived the highs and lows of the
eSports world and it's partially because
fans just love watching their chemistry
both in game and out yep right huh
exactly that's what I'm thinking with
your name as well but a counter-strike
moves fast you can be the best player in
the world one day and wash the next just
look at the MIB our Brazilian core once
two-time major champions and now well
you'd be hard-pressed to see them
lifting a trophy but get written forests
have defied the fast-paced world of
eSports they've managed to stay relevant
as a duo for over a decade their
relationship began in 2009 I then get
right had been playing counter-strike
for a couple of years but he was jumping
from team to team eventually he joined
fnatic which marked the end of his
search for a squad that he could mesh
with but I remember playing against him
the first time
like right off the bat I knew that this
guy is something else I knew this guy
it's gotta be one scary player to play
against and at that moment I knew as
well that I wanted to be played to be
playing with him because I can't stand
playing against this guy anymore so I
was scared when I played against him
first time because yeah he was one
incredible players but get Wright didn't
just find a more permanent home on
fnatic he also found a friend for life
but nothing lasts forever that fnatic
roster eventually broke up and get
Wright went back to his old team SK
gaming but this time he brought along
Forrest I think that me and for us
getting the redemption from getting so
much [ __ ] this year from living in
fnatic so this is just prove me that we
made the right decision given for us
five years on fnatic his departure from
the team was unexpected but not
surprising Forrest and get right were
soul mates on the server and nobody
wanted to see them split up I think we
have the best professional friendship
both me and him talks a lot about things
before and like you know like problems
in real life and whatever and so on we
understood like pretty much that we're
two good players that are feeling that
we are some Senate's perfect match and
even though our planes I was so
differently I think I think what made
made him such a good team that is the
way he understood the game the way he
opened up the map for for you you like
for me to be when we were playing I
think I don't necessarily we don't
didn't necessarily play on the same
positions we weren't even on the same
side of the map when we were playing T
side but what he did do it the way he
communicated the way he opened up spaces
like kinda unlocked me as well as well
as a player on how I should approach the
game and that was one of his biggest
strengths
that's why I think we worked so good I
was an aggressive player he was more
like a laid-back player more information
seeking more backstabbing more lurking
that was his play style I was more
in-your-face play style and that's why I
think we weren't so good because we
didn't have the same same style the pair
stuck together when csgo came out and
joined ninjas and pajamas
off the games era with an undefeated 87
and OMAP streak as you got get right
right they're gonna go ahead and put
that that Molotov right there look how
get white slides through he actually may
come get me right behind that deep air
the office he's still alive inside
behind he's able to take out I know it's
all on our PK he comes infographic at
what position will win it for an IP
gaming calling nip untouchable back then
is a bit of an understatement
nipple winning so much that people
complain they were making csgo boring
yes it feels kind of boring to see that
we're winning all the time and I guess
they weren't deceive is saying the fans
that actually watching say it's turning
team to a boring game and after seven
months the haters got their wish the
streak was broken the Palmas gonna go
down all but a dream coming in from
behind gay arrived with a kill a dream
with another one it's a double kill for
him it's a great turn of events ada was
a triple killer cholent exists if she
loses this one rather that's gonna be it
16:40 versus pro the first team in
history to beat ni p on land nips
unprecedented win streak made forest and
get right two of the biggest names in
counter-strike they were the best
and fans were attracted to that but even
when the competition got fiercer and
forest and get where i started to
struggle the community still loved them
they didn't need to be absolute gods to
keep people's attention sure the win
streak kicked off their fan base but
people kept watching because of their
connection the focus has always been on
us playing together and achieving so
much with each other so I think people
are just like super hyped about that
part when I when I meet us and of course
winning a major didn't hurt either there
is nothing they can do any longer ni p
have won Gamescom 2014
ladies and gentlemen 1613 it finally
happens to second-place finishes that
finally claim the title they are the
champions Gamescom 2014 and despite
fanatics past efforts it goes the
distance
it goes all three maps and we have our
champions the best team in the world
ninjas in pyjamas by winning the major
they reached the pinnacle of yet another
game together forever cementing their
legacy in csgo like everyone it seemed
at that point but especially me and get
rights really wanted that trophy to
further cement our likeliest in the game
right - with a major in csgo we did so
much in 1.6 but I think the major in C
is one of the best tournament wins we
had as a as a duo but the duo's time at
the top didn't last forever after their
win in Cologne nip performance became
sporadic the wins became infrequent as
they dropped from 1st to 2nd to 5th -
bombing out in groups the end of a
legendary streak n IP the only team in
the history of the majors who have made
all 5 finals they've won one of them and
that is its virtus Pro they will be
ending that story but fans didn't care
they loved forest and get rights their
goofy relationship had party captured
the hearts of the entire csgo community
chicken [ __ ] cool chicken [ __ ] poop
[Music]
they were a dangerous duo on the server
but they were also hilarious off of it
you put get right and force in front of
a camera and you're guaranteed to get
comedy gold back in the day when we used
to play was really passionate that man
seeing in the kitchen bringing that
magic it was supposed to be a chef but I
thought it was better with the customers
face to face so I put him up there you
know I'm thinking what's a better thing
so I became the head chef instead
I really thought would the this project
was gonna be something we did together
he always understands what I want I
understand what he wants what did said
honestly we make a perfect team if you
ask and as the years went on he just had
more and more material to work with
should I just no one here I don't like
it that we're kind of lonely here I
can't like it's been a long time since
was only you and me buddy you know I do
want to ask you before we move on you
guys have known each other for years
does this mean you're now an honorary
uncle bow for them would've the trustee
get frightened Forrest didn't need to
what anything else for the community
watching their fun relationship
continued to grow was enough but
Carrigan forests were still competitive
they wanted to win again they wanted to
win together and eventually they did an
IP Evan pitched off they've got the ball
and they've got a minute to think about
this look at that right he's already got
one hand in the air he's waiting for him
he wants that celebration they want the
trophy in there
we'll take down SK on the return of pip
what a story
let's return after a three mums absinthe
a comeback once again and win their
third tournament of the year you can see
what it means to them very emotional
scenes there get right it looks like
he's gonna help hold it together Chris
now don't let it out we love puppy down
to just two low HP players and exist is
getting aggressive Kerrigan might have
to be the hero again this time reverse
boost one of the lines have you seen
that there's red spikes kara get down
inches 34 and 18 HP for rain and Nico
and inside of every dark cloud comes way
but inside of that comes right
I pledged to fight
against the best in the world and an IP
Koufax imagine Oakland
Nippon I am Auckland in 2016 and then
again in 2017 Garrett and Forrest proved
that they weren't washed up but they
were still worthy of the respect and
adoration the community had for them
when we talk about legendary teams
across the ESCO those rosters usually
have a core of three or more players
think fallen fur taco and coldzera for
the old sk roster or olofmeister flush
and JW 4 2015 fnatic but Garrett and
Forrest aren't the core they're a duo
they carved their own completely unique
path to the top of both 1.6 and csgo and
they did it through hard work and
non-stop grinding which shares go plaid
- you respect the most I'm gonna say
like get rid of them Forrest I really
think they are iconic players it's gonna
be a big day once they retire or move
out of gaming it's gonna be like you
know right in the fields moment though
for tickets right so they've made the
sky of magic button over the past decade
fans have gone to know Forrest and get
right as not just professional fraggers
but also just a couple of normal cell
ability on people
the duo felt more like friends you queue
up with an untouchable legend
you must probably say like something
really weird I mean something I've been
listening on a lot like yes pinky
[Music]
dewpoints are in this I'm good sheet I'm
Gucci we got this I know this guy
I say felt because nip announced that
get right was leaving the team after
nearly 11 years together get right and
forests are no longer teammates but yeah
right isn't retiring he just loves the
game too much to step aside is this the
last time we'll see you at Alexis [ __ ]
no so what's next for counterstrikes
greatest duo well both forest and get
right seemed pretty adamant about
continuing to play the game they love
and honestly it's gonna be weird seeing
get right played without forest like it
didn't really hit me until we started
playing in Stockholm that he was not on
my side anymore because once the round
started and we were winning rounds I'm
so used to him heat like screaming you
know high-fiving you know hyping the
team up and like not hearing hearing him
in game either was so weird to me like
it feels like felt like a piece was
missing through the puzzle you know it
was a really weird feeling but even if
they're wearing different jerseys forest
and get raped partnership lives on they
might not be teammates on the server
anymore but their relationship will
continue to exist in the hearts of the
csgo community their relationship
touched csgo fans all around the world
and a roster move isn't gonna change
that thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]